it doesn't have to be your main focus
and and like you said earlier you don't
have to be going after being you know
the strongest man in the world or
anything even close to that but you know
going in and having that that positive
reinforcement of training because it
just carries over before I introduce our
next guest you know this story often
with dealing into a topical news show
people have to get bumped because we
have either people come on a politician
answer people have specific issues
there's something broke that's topical
and you have someone with a book on it
so this next guys has been so friendly
we've had to move him several times
because it's a great idea let me get
this out first at Shaw strength Shaw
strength comm Shaw strength coming in SH
aw we've had to move him several days
four times world Strongest Man that's a
great way sir just piss off the world
Strongest Man Brian Shaw thanks for
being here brother Thank You Stephen I'm
happy to be here well thank you so much
for being so patient and I'm such a big
fan as a matter of fact I have to say
our research or the beast reg is a huge
fan he's actually he's a little guy but
he's got a 600 something raw deadlift
I think a 500 something sorry no 600
Watts quat a 500 watt deadlift at 1/8
he's a university professor so he oh
that's yeah he's great I just don't want
to be on his bad side so world strong
four times unbelievable you know III the
best American strongman competitor for
people who don't know well certainly
some people will argue it but I would
say ever let me have to head what I say
because people will get mad what's that
like and what did you have your flash of
genius moment to say hey I can lift
heavy things and move them faster than
anybody I know you know it's looking
back I don't know if I had one moment
where that kind of occurred to me it was
you know something growing up as a kid I
did you know a lot of manual things my
uncle had a farm so we had to do you
know farm work and that type of thing
and it was just something you did
because we had to do it you know but
looking back you know doing those types
of
things that 11 or 12 years old is
probably a little bit abnormal you know
and like half down every day I have I
have lifted cows before not necessarily
in consecutive days but have done that
so it yeah it's just something that kind
of looking back I think that all the
signs were there but I didn't really
realize how gifted I was until I
actually started competing and and it
just was a natural fit for me after I
started competing it was something that
I just everything came very naturally I
was I was able to move things that other
people couldn't move they go cow-tipping
hey we're gonna go Shh Brian lifted it
Brian what the hell are you doing the
video is some b-roll here of the Atlas
stone if oh gosh this is just it scares
hurts my back to to watch so for people
to know you now you're six eight I think
440 pounds when you started strong man
how big were you I was probably
obviously the same height but about I
would say about 330 pounds or so and
that's I mean gosh going on three well
yeah I mean if skinny is a word at 330
pounds I was skinny you know just
because of my frame you know a that age
and and it's taken me a lot of years to
put that put that weight on you know to
to just increase my lifting leverages
and to be more competitive
yeah well compact come on you're being
so much competitive four times we're all
strongest man like just took you know I
just I just I just want to go the
distance and be still standing no you
won world Strongest made four times um
it's unbelievable well you have a nine
hundred five pound squat your tire
deadlift is 11 hundred forty pounds
really don't know it's just unbelievable
stuff and actually my producer here he
he has been putting on weight you know
he had I think I'm not letting the
Canada bag you know all sort of colitis
so I had a big part of them test and
removed and he's struggled with gaining
weight for a long time and he's been
lifting like
and what what do you want to say what
you're up to I don't want to I'm up to
oh I don't have a squat machine her
squat proper squat about 200 is what I'm
up to on I mean your weight though your
weight weight yeah up to 161 which for
him is is really so what advice would
you have for someone like him who isn't
just I don't want to drink milk but
actually had you know a disorder that
led to him struggling with it because I
know I know he's curious he's too shy to
ask because he's afraid of you it's I
mean obviously that's about the hurdle
that he's gonna he's gonna have to
overcome and something that a lot of
people don't have to deal with but gain
you a time and I get that question very
very frequently you know and the the
typical question is just like oh I'm
trying so hard to eat and you know I
can't gain weight but when it really
comes down to it eating if you're really
serious about trying to gain weight it
has to be a job I mean it's you've got
to be eating whether you're hungry or
not every couple hours from when you
wake up to when you go to bed you know
so it's it's the commitment you can't
have one day of good eating and then the
next day you kind of need two or three
smaller meals and then go back to it
it's it's just something where you know
for me I would like when I was younger I
was really trying to gain weight I would
just pack an entire cooler and take it
to work with me and then I would have to
eat the the contents of that cooler by
the end of the day and then start and do
it all again you know college you have
to bring food for the whole team get
away all the reasons I've seen results
this time around just is just that it's
just being really good it's the most
consistent I've ever been with just
eating your day and I realize you work
out you just prospects a hunger you know
you you got a go suppers you eat which
gives you energy to workout so it's kind
of it's a silikal sort of fun winsome
thing 4:40 here you come Brian let me
ask you this because I'm always
interested and you know this show
obviously have a lot of a lot of
political figures and deal with cultural
issues but to me I'm always fascinated
by people who are the best in any field
excellent even though I hate soccer 7
computer knows I still have a crevice
pectoralis you couldn't pay me to watch
it
so for people who aren't maybe
necessarily following strong man and
aren't as familiar with you
you four times world Strongest Man that
is so elite was there a turning point
because he kind of struggled for a while
you were coming in third and second and
then rattled off first-place finishes
like there it seems to a viewer like
there was a turning point you know what
that was for you um you know it's when I
got my first taste of of going to world
Strongest Man I'm a to say I'm
competitive
it's kind of an understatement and I've
been that way my entire life from when I
was a kid I mean I I can't imagine how
many problems I caused from our parents
play and I mean I was wandering the
Monopoly board my god exactly so you
know for me it was something once I got
to that level and worked so hard to get
there I wanted to win very badly so my
focus was a hundred percent on a daily
basis on being the best that I possibly
could be so you know it was it's
literally a lifestyle that I that I have
to live and to get to that level you
know I mean you want to be the best like
you said of anybody in the world that's
something you're gonna have to commit
yourself fully to doing that and it's
not easy and you know you have to work
through tough days you have to work
through challenges overcome a lot of
different things but you know once I got
that taste of it that was kind of my
turning point where I knew that I had
the capability to win and that just
drove me even harder yeah I had a
question I mean obviously most of our
fans aren't competing in you know
World's Strongest Man competitions but a
lot of people like Marc Roberto talked
about how the benefits of anyone getting
stronger can can you speak to kind of
like what what benefits that people need
to know about that that just being
stronger is is good period yeah that's a
huge huge point I mean it's it's
something where I I would say that
everybody in my opinion should workout
should train because it teaches you so
much about yourself there and you know
as you go in and put that work in and
you see results it's kind of a positive
you know a positive effect that
continues to happen and then you have a
more positive self-image you know and it
just carries over to the rest of your
life yeah I mean it teaches you so much
about yourself just
raining in general you know so I I think
that absolutely everybody should work
out I think it's something that it can
be such a positive thing the measurable
progress is what we we talking about
that measurable increase of with a wait
it's a number it's a mathematical number
whereas some other things you know we
have a lot of combat athletes doing
Brazilian [ __ ] so you are boxing you
have some good days and bad days the
barbell the kilograms don't lie though I
will say I've never once gotten down to
my car me like I can go to work if I
just move that 560 pound rock never once
happen no it's I don't you know no but
mark reptilia who's written starting
strength and he talks about that how
you're obviously listen I know I hate to
use a term freak athlete but you always
have a genetic component you know not
everyone is six eight people can try as
they might maybe not be the world's
strongest man some people aren't very
fast some people have you know some some
hurdles but everyone can get stronger
than they were and I think that's the
takeaway that a lot of people miss when
talking about self-esteem we're not
saying you're strong per se just
stronger than you were yeah absolutely
you can you can improve yourself and and
you know it's it doesn't have to be your
main focus and and like you said earlier
you don't have to be going after being
you know the strongest man in the world
or anything even close to that but you
know going in and having that that
positive reinforcement of training
because it just carries over you know
anybody that's worked out regularly will
understand that how you feel after you
go in and work out it's just a very
uplifting feeling and being able to put
even even five more pounds on on the
barbell and lift it that's a positive
effect that you can measure and it's
something that makes you feel good about
yourself absolutely yeah absolutely one
thing about say you know and and forgive
me if every overstepping my bounds but I
think these are this is out there
watched pretty much all the strong men
documentaries out there and also the
YouTube semi documentaries on you you
have a wonderful wife mrs. Shaw who
seems very supportive and she seems to
have a very deep understanding of you
your idiosyncrasies one to give you
space when you're competing my wife is
like that you know when I do stand up or
do the show she knows okay give give him
some space here here's where I need
support how important would you say that
is is having someone like that
the complementary roles and a unit to
make it happen because you seem to have
that in spades yeah I am definitely very
lucky to have my wife you know I mean
it's something where it's a big
commitment what I have to do but having
her there to support me and and like you
said she she knows when to kind of give
me a little bit of room and when when I
need to talk or when you know when to
you know cuz I good days and bad days
too I mean I come in from coming from
training or something and I'm just kind
of like man that I just didn't go the
way I wanted it to go or something and
then you know she just kind of knows how
to pick me up and to support me and I
mean she does so much stuff honestly so
much stuff behind the scenes that people
never see you know and um I'm kind of
the guy that people look at and say okay
well you know Brian went to this contest
and performed or won or whatever it is
and you know the credit doesn't
necessarily go back to her but but she
was helping me with so many things
around the house and and making my life
easier so that I can go Trainmen and do
what I need to do to perform yeah and um
not in that support system is massively
important yeah I don't when I watch the
documentary it was very very touching to
me when I would hear her speak and
listen you're also a very bright guy in
a sensitive guy we just talked we talked
about having Laci green aside you have
toxic masculinity and I have to be big
and aggressive and you can express your
emotions I think you're a great walking
example of someone who is what we talked
about I don't know if you're familiar
with this I've talked about this in the
show a lot the term was originally
jack-of-all-trades master of one and
then it got turned into Jack altijd
master of none but the mockery has
become the colloquialism the idea was
you're not a complete man unless you're
physically emotionally spiritually kind
of in line and and you're obviously very
articulate and you people watch these
documentaries you seem like somebody
who's very comfortable in his own skin
what do you say to a lot of people who
think of strongmen or athletes sort of
in that in that millyar as meatheads
yeah I mean that's a it's it's something
you know it's just a generalization that
people make and they assume that okay
well if you're you're competing in the
sport and you know it's a very
asked you once for obviously and and
we're having to do these things and it's
kind of a you know for lack of a better
term an alpha male you know type of
sport and and you know I mean we're
going after the the the world Strongest
Man title you know it's it's something
that you know a lot of guys do get
caught up in that but you know for the
most part a lot of strong men are
actually very well-educated men that you
know maybe outside of the contest you
have to be able to flip that that
competitor switch when you're competing
but when you stepped out of that arena
off that stage most of us are very
humble guys and and pretty down-to-earth
I mean you have you have a few that are
not that way and they kind of keep that
persona and they're you know not very
nice to people and that kind of thing
but you know for the most part it's um
you know something I think for me it
kind of came from my upbringing for my
parents you know always remain humble
and be thankful and you know that's that
type of thing and and I just tried to
carry that on even with all the success
that I've had and you know going to
these bigger competitions and having
more people follow me and watch me in
that type of thing that doesn't
necessarily mean that that humbleness
has to go away or that that I need to
take on this persona of being a meathead
or whatever you know it's it's something
that but a lot of I don't do I
appreciate that I appreciate that you
don't because you know there's nothing
more corrosive potentially than humans
sold and success and obviously you're
about as successful as you can be in
this endeavor and you could easily have
come on here and been been a jerk and
you could have we could say nothing we
couldn't say anything in your opinion
obviously is as four-time winner who
would you say and there's a lot of
debate about this in your opinion who's
the strongest man who's ever lived you
can't include yourself it's not fair
that is that is a tough debate it's it's
a debate that you know you go into any
sport and you can you it's it's hard to
compare eras right of any sport and
that's that's really where the debate
comes so you know you've had several
different men that have kind of
dominated their respective era of
strongmen so you know the first one
probably being Bill Kazmaier
yeah you know I mean
he was very very dominant in in
strongman in powerlifting you know
especially in the early 80s it was early
to mid 80s little dollar than your
starting size yes it's crazy I mean he's
actually still a pretty big guy yeah you
know in in in a lot of ways but you know
the guys have just got bigger overall
you know and and it's so I would say
that on that list you have built as
learn then one of my main rivals oh oh
no oh no it's a suspense he just cut I'm
willing to base it's gonna say oh sorry
I can use if ickis is that what you're
about to say could add the dream is to
Vegas yeah okay yeah so him and I have
gone back and forth World's Strongest
Man we both at four world Strongest Man
titles so I would I would put him on
that list and then you know you'd have
to you know there's there's kind of
legendary strongmen from the past and
probably the top one of those it's Louis
Cyr you know you seems rather young
competitor Quebec oh yeah the back
people for people who don't know the
back lift chair you have to do the
longshot the back lift is where you
would put weight on here like people
would and you do this and literally lift
it like this when people now they go
back lift I'm like no you don't Louis
Cyr I said from what I understand the
record still hasn't been broken but as
far as I know it has not yeah so I mean
he's probably from all the legendary you
know strongmen at the past he's probably
got the best documented feats of
strength of anybody and I mean there's
you know one of the biggest contests we
have we actually get a the trophy as a
statue of Louis Cyr yeah so it's pretty
cool so I mean he's he's definitely held
in very high regard in the strength
community still you know after after all
these years so oh sorry my dog was
growling there I don't know if he didn't
like Lee series he walked into the
studio Hoffer but okay here's something
again and I know you're so competitive
so you don't have to answer if it's a
sore spot but again when I have someone
who's the best in their field there are
certain issues that fascinate me okay
and I can ask this now I think please
don't hurt me because you
went on to win four times but like I
said the victus was your main rival and
there is a moment I remember when I was
watching world's strongest my camera
which year it was but it was it was a
log lift I think was the Austrian oak
and as far as I remember it no one else
had lifted it yet some kind of overhead
lift and then I think you were the first
one to do it and you got a rep or two
and then I remember the Vic us getting
in because that was his lift listen
difference from it and he just wrapped
it out like it was a like it was a baby
again I don't say that's it because then
you went in you you came back and you
won this is not a slight at all but what
was that moment like for you because it
was so mind-blowing how how strong he
wasn't very specific facets back then
sure we I mean there was I don't know
exactly what moment you're talking about
there but there was definitely times
where he had events especially with the
log because I that's I'm he's been
pretty open saying that's been his
favorite lifts by far overall and so he
had those moments with the log whereas I
had kind of those moments with lifting
stones which is more of kind of my
specialty yeah lifts where you know he
couldn't do those things so in a lot of
ways I think that's what made our
rivalry great yeah is that he had
different strengths than I did in and it
was always trying to keep up you know
for me keep up with him the best I could
unlock like his vet best events and then
the same for him yeah and I think that
we we forced each other to get better
which made it you know it made it great
yeah it really was an area that was very
fun to watch and I just asked because I
always wondered what it's like to be
like the world's the strongest guy
everywhere you go and then in one event
one guy is just you're like I like it
Philippians 1 one word is frustrated
that it was you know because you put all
this hard training into doing it and
then you know if you go and have an
event like that where he would do so
well and I had trained so hard to be
better at it it was just kind of like
man you walk away frustrated from
moments like that for sure yeah
well and it's also important note
strength athletes tend to kind of a
better they come into their prime a
little later and so that's what kind of
happened and there's a you know what's
the age gap there and and and then you
went on to win you know I said four four
four I don't know if it was four
consecutive I think there might have
been a gap in there with one injury yeah
so the years were 2011 2013 and then
2015 and 2016 I had a couple a couple in
the middle there that it didn't work out
but you know it's overall it's the
longevity very concerned that's that's
like you said with with strength
athletes it's much different because as
you age you get stronger but your
training has to change a little bit and
I'm learning that more and more all the
time is you know I can't train in the
same way as when I was 25 ROM you know
it just takes a little bit longer to
recover but I'm stronger so it's kind of
trying to find that rhythm of how hard
to work and and how much energy to put
in a training and allowing yourself
still to recover and get stronger so ya
know I know I always found it
fascinating when I was younger to ask
the older guys all the questions because
they had already been through the
battles and they had already kind of
figured everything out and most of them
said that the strongest they ever felt
was kind of in their late 30s to around
40 yeah that's kind of where they felt
like they were their absolute strongest
so you know hopefully with that being
said I'm still creeping up on that so so
we can get a couple more good years
that'll be great
I had crazy old man strength to Brian
Shaw this stuff that gets kids
nightmares let me ask you this since you
brought that up in that well I know
you're busy we have to get going
as someone who's 6-8 you know over 400
pounds when you retire what are your
plans are you planning on honestly still
training it seems like one thing I know
strong men seem to maintain it more than
say like bodybuilders they seem to stay
like Bill Kazmaier is still in it but do
you plan on shedding staying strong but
shedding some weight so you're it's not
on your joints as much you know probably
I mean I will I'll probably try to try
to lose some weight just based on the
fact that I won't be competing right you
know and so I don't need to be as big
but I mean for me with my friend might I
don't know how
much way to lose but if I lose you know
50 or 60 pounds that would probably be
enough you know and I'd probably feel
great even losing that much weight you
know and so but my goal I'm still gonna
work out I mean I you know the from when
I found weightlifting in high school you
know I never stopped and I I really and
truly just loved it
you know it's not something where you
know for me if I wasn't competing and
strong then I would still be working out
just because yeah it's it's been a
consistent thing and you know I think
you mentioned earlier you know a 45
pound bar is always gonna weigh 45
pounds and a 45-pound plate it's always
gonna weigh 45 times and the weights
don't care if you've had a good day or a
bad day or whatever and so for me the
way I've always kind of look at it is
training is then a consistent in my life
always and I could always go put that
that work in to working out and feel
better about myself so it's it's
something for me I'll definitely
maintain that training and and still do
it because for me it's fun yeah first
and foremost and I'm not at all
suggesting you need to lose weight I
just know when speaking with a lawyer we
have a lot of like Margaret Vito who is
a powerlifting a lot of guys like well
yeah I don't need to keep this weight up
like I need it for maximal strength but
as I get older longevity even the Brawn
does a big thing he shed some weight so
you can you know career I mean you know
I'm the upper side of 6-2 tall guys it's
just it's just a reality you know if we
don't it we don't live as long term
times because of just the levers and the
constant torque so obviously don't worry
about that now because you're the
strongest man in the world I always
wanted as you as you grow as you as you
grow out of it
it's it's it's a whole life long journey
mr. Shaw is Shaw I want to make sure I
have your Twitter right tell strength a
sha strength and then it's a it's sha
strength comm where where can people
best follow your si I know you speak a
lot where should people look for you
next
really I'll kind of kind of be all over
the place I mean I'm still competing
actively us I still got that going on
and you know I post a lot try to post a
lot on Instagram and that's just sha
strength as well on there and and I try
to kind of document so
my travels on there a little bit more
but yeah it's there and then trying to
put more content on YouTube as well I
mean that was a lot of fun what's the
YouTube channel it's also show strength
shop strength yep
good no no we've been putting some
putting some fun stuff out on there and
hopefully hopefully be able to keep some
some fun content coming yeah in the
future with that as well and just soon
if you want to get more flowers in
Instagram
yoga pants in booty pictures I've
noticed that seems to be very popular
just Bryan Shaw doing the Coppertone ad
all right that's a thank you so much
Brian Shaw and we would love to have you
back and next time I promise it won't be
so long I really appreciate you
answering some some personal questions
I've just always been fascinated and was
really curious thank you so much for
having me on
hey if you like this video subscribe or
click the notification but you should do
both anyways because youtube doesn't
notify you if you're just subscribe you
have to hit that notification bell so if
you already are subscribed hit the
notification bell and if you're not
supporting this content good a lot it
was kinda come slush monk let me get the
full nightly show an hour every day free
when you subscribe this hand - girthy
mug as well as other programming and
listen you also get to support not caged
yards Remicade treatment i don't know
what it is I know it has something
because he has yes he had all sort of
colitis it doesn't anymore thank God
because there moved his colon and truth
be told it's not working very well
anyway